bekommen anrufe dass sie verbrauchen
roboter einen igel gefunden haben der
vorübergeht hat über den igel waren es
typisch ist also die gesichtsverletzung
und dann noch seitlich die verletzung
jeder tierarzt würde das einschläfern
und wir haben gesagt wir probieren ist
und wenn man das foto vorhersieht wir da
aus gesehen worden jetzt sieht dann weiß
man dass man auf dem richtigen weg sind
und geht es darum dass man dass die
leute aufmerksam gemacht werden die
einen rausch
roboter haben und dass man vielleicht
auch die hersteller darauf aufmerksam
macht dass man geräte mit sensor baut
die wo trifft hier erkennen es ist ja
nicht nur der igel ist ist ja eidechsen
amphibien insekten alles wird vernichtet
durch den rasen roboter und der igel ist
der meist betroffene sozusagen mit den
schweren verletzungen
wenn man einen rasen roboter hat sollte
man in ändern am tag laufen lassen und
nicht in der nacht und zum anderen dass
die menschen die den haben dass sie den
rasen absuchen
das wäre riesen hilfe für die tiere
[Musik]